Москва руками Лукашенка намагається
провокувати збройний конфлікт на кордоні
з Польщею штучно організована міграційна
криза готувалася заздалегідь впевнений в
тому що це лише частина плана Путіна
позагостренню
оперативної обстановки на всьому
східному флангу НАТО першочерговим на
сьогоднішній день є питання ситуації на
кордонах яка залишається надзвичайно
небезпечно ворог вже воріт гримає в наші
двері і ми вимагаємо невідкладно
застосувати весь наявний захід і
інвентар досвіду підключивши парламент
дефенсів webens
Just The price for Путін і вхід сайт
ви українське суспільство має перед
загрозою вторгнення Путіна об'єднатися
Ми Точно маємо отримати Сполучених
Штатів починаючи від Контр батарейних
станцій для підвищення ефективності дій
української артилерії і завершуючи
станції радіоелектронної боротьби
починаючи від
зенітних ракет Patriot і завершуючи
сучасними
дифенсів weapence які конче потребує
український збройні сили після
восьмирічного досвіду війни
перелік видів озброєння які терміново
мають бути надані в Україні українські
воїни мають Пройти навчання бо наступний
наступ буде
в тому числі застосування
військово-повітряних сил Україна не
просить щоб натівські солдати воювали за
наш суверенітет ми маємо з найкращих в
світі збройних сил які здатні дати
відповідь
[музика]
to Ukraine
дефенсів літо у вепрс Путін залишив всю
військову техніку це є індикатор того що
Путін готується до війни
розміщення в прикордонній Території
розвідувальних і інших засобів це є
поганий індикатор побудова
логістики яка будується це є також дуже
тривожний сигнал ми маємо скликати Раду
національної безпеки і оборони
запросивши туди лідерів фракції всіх
включаючи опозиційні бо ця дискусія має
відбутися на об'єднання суспільства на
об'єднання народу і об'єднання країни
для того щоби підвищити здатність
України давати відсіч агресору
українська нація має з одного боку
об'єднатися а з іншого боку світ має
продемонструвати тверду Солідарність з
Україною і робиться це лише з однією
метою для того щоб підвищити для Путіна
ціну у випадку якщо він прийме
божевільне рішення про
продовження російської агресії
проросійський наступ вимагаємо
адекватної реакції української влади
адекватної підготовки країни до
можливого ймовірного сценарію вторгнення
мова йдеться і про підняття грошового
забезпечення мова йдеться і про нарешті
комплектацію стратегічних резервів і про
виділення коштів місцевому
самоврядування для розгортання негайного
систем територіальної оборони
для того комплектації
державна оборонного замовлення закупівлі
паливно-мастильних матеріалів харчеїв
резерви речового
медичного і іншого забезпечення про
негайне збільшення військової
[музика]
терміново наповнити пусті стратегічні
резерви доля дає нам трохи часу ми маємо
знати що у нас все напоготові Україна
потребує ще більш оборонної зброї в тому
числі і в першу чергу
протиповітряної і протиракетної якщо
рушниця висить на стіні Вона обов'язково
вистрілила